do you believe the Earth is round yes
okay well you're totally wrong you now
if I say to you is the earth flat you
you'll be right if you say no right but
we have proven that though cuz it's here
so the Earth is not a perfect sphere it
has some spherical property it's
actually pretty oblate it has properties
like a pair and even if I said it's pair
shaped I'm also wrong but it's getting
closer and closer to the scientific
truth science is not about saying
provable facts again we can't prove that
the Earth is a prolate spheroid with the
way that I can prove 2 + 2 equal 4 even
though that'll take 400 pages of
abstract mathematics to prove that
simple sounding statement you can't say
oh you have one finger you have no no no
that's not what we're talking about but
there is no such thing as proving
physically that the Earth is a sphere or
a pair or whatever shape you want a
donut but what you should do is say
things that are accurate as much as you
can with precision